hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar debunking antibody titration
meds I am Julie abbing of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by sciotech biosciences to learn more
visit scitec bio.com we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation I'd now like to welcome our
speaker Deanna Bonilla Global scientific
director of scitec biosciences Deanna
you may now begin your presentation
well hello everyone thank you so much
for joining us today this talk is about
a simple but relevant topic antibody
titration we all know how critical
antibodies are for flow cytometry and
part of that depends on titration so the
goal for this presentation is to show
you how titration is key and also to
address some questions and
misconceptions around on the topic
so if we start with kind of the how the
presentation is organized I divide it
into two topics the first section is
going to be an introduction on titration
best practices and the second part is
going to be some comparisons we did for
over 100 titrations across different
variables different conjugates
specificity so we will go there uh later
uh the antibodies are so useful for many
Technologies right Western blood flow
cytometry immunohistochemistry Elisa and
in terms of the structure it's the same
immunoglobulins have two heavy chains
you see them in yellow to light change
on the sides also as part of the
structure immunoglobulins have variable
regions those variable regions are
important for binding to specific
antigens or epitose within the antigens
and the constant region more for
functionality there are multipolar five
subclasses or isotypes of
immunoglobulins they are different
functions but also on house you see for
IGM and IGA for their different number
of antigen binding sites
[Music]
let's first review some important
Concepts before we dive into titration
this is The Binding of an antibody and
an antigen that's what we call an immune
complex so for the immune complex
important things are the specificity we
want an antibody to bind specifically
the unique epitope in the antigen in
terms of caffeine that does the strength
of that binding ability also the overall
strength so depends on Affinity but also
on anything else that can help stabilize
the complex things like how many antigen
binding sites are present in the
antibody how many binding sites in the
antigen any thing that could help the
molecules interact things like having
your antigen immobilize and other
factors more technical ones like
temperature time of incubation and and
staining conditions
when we uh talk about validation of
antibody it's it's kind of good title
but antibodies are not magical it's not
just getting the bile and start using it
it's all the validation that might be
needed and related to that there are
three Publications uh in nature the last
decade that highlight the issues with
using antibodies that are part of the
reproducing relief crisis that we see in
science but the key point and message
from those Publications is that you want
to test your antibody in your cells of
Interest under the staining conditions
that you plan to use in your samples and
in order to verify that it's performing
um
well
back in 2016 a proposal was signed by
more than 100 investigators to have
guidelines on antibody use and
validation of these uh reagents so in
response to that there's so many portals
now or websites with information on how
to use antibodies but also validation
data which is so critical so that's the
place where you could start identifying
clones and antibodies to use
what are the issues with antibodies and
kind of summarizing what was described
in those Publications main issues are
three uh at least the ones reported by
them cross-reactivity your antibody
binding not only to your protein of
interest but something else specifically
or non-specifically through the anti and
binding size of the yellow portions of
the orange portions or through the FC
portion in the constant region variation
across Lots with different performance
or just picking the wrong antibody we
know for example for Western blood you
are going to be detecting linear
epitopes versus for flow cytometry more
of the Native form of the protein but
even if all of that is control we have
seen how in flow cytometry there's
differences in performance for
antibodies and that's related to other
factors what clone you're using not only
because that's what's giving you the
specificity but also because some clones
tend to aggregate more for example the
conjugates the type of lure but also its
stability the cell type the critical
part that's where the antigens are going
to be expressed for then antibodies to
bind staining protocol because anything
in the staining protocol could affect
that binding capacity things like
temperature incubation times washes all
the buffers that could affect the
binding but also the levels of
expression and definitely titration and
that's why it's the center of this
presentation
as you see on the right side on the
bottom there is uh some Publications
that have addressed how critical
titration is for high quality data so
what I've done is summarize in Four
Points why you definitely want to go for
titration or complete titration for
every reagent higher resolution you're
maximizing your positive signal
minimizing the noise also by increasing
reproducibility because you have
consistency in the protocol that you're
using and that including the
concentration of antibody that is used
the specificity of your staining because
you reduce the chances to have crows uh
binding or non-specific binding by
optimizing the concentration also
related more to technical things your
signal is going to be on scale less
spillover spreading between
fluorochromes since the signal is dimmer
and also less Aggregates antibody
Aggregates and also the chances to have
your target cells aggregating because of
the presence of those immune complexes
and something more not related to data
quality but more to the efficiency of
the assay which is saving money most of
the time the optimal titer is less than
what the uh that the recommended
concentration
so if we move forward one of the
questions that we get is when should I
be titrating my reagent so the answer
for sure is if you have a new assay and
for every antibody and any fluorescent
molecule so biability dies
functionalized need to be titrated as
well once you type trade or optimize
your assay you might need to retit if
there is anything new New Lots clones
conjugates anything changing in the
protocol same in protocol that could
affect binding capacity and definitely
there is something suspicious about the
data uh your refrigerator is not working
uh reagents were left in the bench
exposed to light and storage conditions
and go all of that could be impacting
your antibody performance
there is also a lot of Publications that
include titration data as part of their
panel validation and this is where our
example a panel optimized by psych tech
two years ago is a 40 color panel so
here I'm just showing you the titration
how they look we will go deep on how
analyze the data but this is for the
Biola dice the same has been defined or
explained in the manuscript for every
single reagent just to show you one
example this is a titration for ieg on
the y-axis you will see the intensity of
the signal on the x-axis you will see
the concentrations that were tested from
2 to 125 nanograms per test in this case
and we clearly see using only two there
is not a clear separation for the
positives but if you use 125 now we see
better the separation important thing if
you want to use this as a resource is
that in the publication now you will
have a table that is listing every
single fluorochrome every single reagent
with the specificity the floor
information about the vendor and also
what tighter was used once again in
nanograms per test important to report
as concentration
and important to to consider normally
the titration grade panel design the
staining protocol all of that together
will allow you to then generate data
that is high quality in other words at
the resolution the separation for all
the populations in the panel is optimal
let's divide the titration process into
three parts what do you need to have
ready before you even start staining
samples or acquiring samples on your
cytometry so four recommendations
starting with sample quality making sure
you have enough positive events that
your sample for titration it's repressed
is a good representation of what you
will have in your multi-color uh testing
in your final experiment that you pick
carefully the Clone based on validation
data using all those portals and then
based on Sample characteristics or
quality you can decide whether you need
to include a viability die block your FC
receptors lies your red blood cells or
include co-staining that's highly useful
if you're gonna detect a low express
marker in order to find clearly the
positivity so you could include a
lineage marker C3 CDA to identify things
like TCR Gamma Delta easier in the
titration
in terms of assay design a lot of
considerations in the staining protocol
what's your stock concentration antibody
stock uh what concentrations are you
testing what dilutions uh the final
staining volume should match what you
will have in your multi-color sample
when all the other antibodies will be
added acquisition details how many
events you're recording also based on
the frequency of the population what are
your acquisition settings ideally
optimized um for your cells of interest
and flow rate uh as well that something
that could be predefined
if you don't know the stock
concentration you can reach out to the
manufacturer and get information if
you're using a scitec antibody or
conjugate you can go to our webpage and
find the certificate of analysis and
with that you will get a document that
document will look like this and in
green highlighted the concentration so
that's where you start from uh the uh
other part of the pre preparation for
your titration is understand how you're
gonna do data analysis
which populations are going to be gated
how to define uh for example uh which um
the scripted statistics will be used if
you're calculating any metrics how you
will Define the optimal title the fact
that you can concatenate all the samples
to have a better picture of the full
titration and also based on that decide
whether you need to test additional
titrations and finally understand that
titration it's a dynamic process when
you for steps one two and three when you
are in a single color scenario the
background that you're getting will
depend on the cells out of fluorescence
will depend on the instrument what
settings you use and how much noise
you're getting and it's going to depend
also on the antibody how much
non-specific binding you're getting or
even unwanted specific bind
so when you move into multi-color
scenario other things are going to play
a role now that multiple antibodies are
added together either spillover
spreading between floors or an issue
with the binding percent the
accessibility of the Target and that's
more towards uh steric hindrance the
point is that the final title that you
optimize in one two three can change you
might need to adjust the title or even
adjust the staining protocol on based on
the results go for a final adjustment on
the floor that was selected for a
particular um antibody
there is also a lot of Publications you
will see them listed on the right that
go through protocols step by step on how
to do titration so if you want a
detailed protocol I suggest you to go
there here's more to describe the
process and give you some tips so we
start with the stock uh let's say this
we are testing titrating CD4 antibody SK
3 Clone conjugated to byg 781 one of our
scitec um dice
you're going to start doing serial
dilutions most of them work in a range
from one to two uh milligrams per test
down to eight things can change
depending on the market the specificity
for example for cd20 you might need to
go higher for c62 uh ligand you you
might be lower around 100 so this might
need to be adapted is to General
recommendation and in terms of tips make
sure that your cytometry is fully
operational your passing you see that
your settings are optimized that will be
in our uh case cytic acid settings that
you find the stock concentration again
through the manufacturer but you keep
consistency in what's going to be the
final staining volume for all those
titration tubes and also consistency in
the number of cells that are going to be
used our suggestion is to go from a to
12 to full cilia dilutions and better
results for us diluting and staining in
plates
try to report the nanograms per test or
micrograms per ml concentration instead
of just the dilution mainly because
stock concentrations can be different
in terms of staining centrifuge the the
antibody vial to remove any antibody
Aggregates taking the article from the
top and important that you match the
staining conditions for that you will
have in your multicolor sample because
anything in that staining condition or
protocol that could affect binding of
the antibody is going to impact the tire
so now let's see what you would do after
you get your FCS files ready
first step is to evaluate sample quality
but I want to talk about uh the key
concept that we will be describing from
now on and it's the optimal titer the
optimal title is going to be the
concentration of antibody that will give
you the best resolution separation
between your positives and your
negatives or between your positive
signal and the background what I'm
showing you here is that titration of
CD4 by g781 but what we are seeing is
different from the not in terms of
concentration different from the numbers
that I was saying telling you before 0.5
to 64 nanograms per test and we will see
why that's the case but going back to
sample quality what I wanted to show you
so for every file you want to check that
you can Define your population of
interest and that's first scatter
pseudocolor plot that you remove from
the analysis uh cell doublet cell
Aggregates that you use time to monitor
the stability of the signal that then
you can Define your negatives and
positives all the statistics needed and
that finally if you have a spectral
cytometry you will be able to see for
every detector in the system how much
light is being captured and build those
signatures so you will know that the
signature for your negative should have
low background versus the signal for
your positive in this case should match
the expected emission from byg 781 as we
see all that emission out of the uh
yellow green detectors
and a consideration back to that idea
that I'm testing lower concentrations
that I had suggested before is because
when we did from a to thousand what we
see is mainly saturation the mfi the
median intensity of fluorescence for the
positives is at the same place
and we are not capturing the initial
part of that titration curve so for this
case we added additional dilutions and
that's something you might need to
consider on the lower end or the higher
end depending on what you are seeing but
if we focus on the uh image or the
concatenated image on the right we are
looking at what's key for titration
negatives and positives if we start with
the positives what we see is using 0.5
the first dilution on the left
0.5 nanograms per test what we are
getting is separating is the CD4 but
it's not saturating so this is
separating concentration you increase
the concentration and you see how the
mfis start increasing and we reach a
point where there is saturation no
matter that if you are adding 1000
nanograms per test the mfi continues to
be the same or close the same
that's for the positives so if we look
at the negatives if we look at the
negative 4.5 concentration it's really
tight low spread in that population but
as soon as we increase antibody
concentration we see the spread of the
negatives so at the end the optimal
tighter that gives me the best
resolution will be the one that gives me
saturation in the positive High signal
and slow spread low mfi in the negative
let's see now what metrics could help me
uh evaluate the data and also Define the
optimal title you're going to have
negatives and positives ideally for each
title you're going to be using things
like the M median intensity mfi for the
positive and the negative and a way to
understand how much the negative the
spread of the negative so there's uh
multiple metrics that have been used
signal to noise ratio is one of them
dividing by the positive by mfi of the
negative stain index you subtract those
two and also divide by two times the
spread of the negative in terms of
robust standard deviation the other one
is the separation index also accounts
for the spread in the negative but in a
different way in terms of the
mathematical calculation it's going to
give more weight to the right side of
that negative histogram because it's the
one that is indicating actual separation
from the positives so it's going to
calculate or based on the calculation of
the 84 percentile and finally something
that we highly suggest and is that
together with a metric calculation for
the separation go with the percentage of
positive cells that you maintain with
going lower and Tighter or higher you
maintain your ability to capture the
positivity within uh your population
back to that CD4 byg 781 titration now
showing you the metrics plotted when we
have the metric value versus the uh
concentration so what we are seeing here
is just the median very difficult with
the median to look at the negatives the
green lines almost down to zero but if I
move to for example log scaling I can
see better how the negatives are also
increasing in mfi but again metrics can
give you just one value can give you a
better idea let's plot signal to noise
ratio we see how things are increasing
because of the increase in the mfi
reaching a plateau but then decreasing
that value because the mfi of the
negative is also increasing
for a stain index you can just plot the
row stain index or the lock to see
better the plateau but same observations
right an increase in that separation
because an increase in intensity for the
positives and then the plateau and even
a decrease because how the negatives are
behaving because of the non-specific
binding
similar observations for separation
index also in log scale
so a lot of ways to plot this and to
calculate from all of them and we will
see part of the comparisons is around
metrics but the observation here is that
for all of those the optimal
concentration is 32 nanograms per test
for this particular antibody and also
important to monitor the percentage of
positive cells for CD4 might be easier
it's easy to find what's positive even
when you use 0.5 nanograms so still
separating the difference between
separating concentrations and saturating
ones once you reach the plateau and we
will see why that's critical in this
slide so if we look at the titration
curve and the different portions let's
uh
dive in starting with the uh initial
part where the antibody concentration is
slow you're not getting sufficient
staining and you see the separation in
the pseudocolor plot of the negatives
and the positives in this area it is
there's going to be a lot of influence
by tiny changes in the protocol
including a technical errors pipetting
errors changes in the temperature in the
incubation time it's going to be having
more impact because of there's we
haven't reached the saturation Point yet
then the next part of that uh curve is
going to be the saturation where you
have the optimal staining and that's
where the optimal title rely if we look
at the sort of color plot now we see how
the positives are much better separated
so in this area the impact of other
variables like time or like incubation
time will not be as high because you're
still already at saturation so tiny
modifications including a technical or
or yeah technical errors that's going to
be um not as impacting as if you are in
a non-saturated concentration and after
that when we see the decline are the
excess of antibody you now are getting
higher background separation is not
improved if we look at the pseudo-color
plot positives are almost at the same
mfi we were seeing that in the
concatenated image as well but now the
negatives look different there's a lot
of spread in four maybe not that
critical I know where the positives are
still but for molecules that are deeply
expressed that's going to have a high
impact
so once again uh the uh optimal title is
going to be right in that saturation
phase and what the way you could
calculate that it's by finding a fit for
that curve Maybe by using a non-linear
regression and the optimal title tends
to be like twofold the
um concentration that gives you 90
percent of the um intensity highest
intensity in terms of mfi
we wanted to analyze a lot of titrations
or more than 100 so we wanted to do this
in an automated way uh and also less
biased way so we got help from FCS
Express they created a universal
titration template for us that is not
available in their website where you
just add the files the find what
concentrations you're testing Define
what populations of interest you have
and finally it's going to do all the
batch analysis and calculation for you
including things like those regression
plots right the concentration versus the
metric that we want to use for
resolution and then the calculation of
what's the optimal title based on the
different metrics that was highly useful
because now we wanted to use that
template uh in order to compare across
things the multiple things where it
comparison I'll review in detail each of
them main questions for all these
comparisons was if the optimal title
influenced by things that I do with
myself by things that I do with my files
but the type of file that I use fares on
the calculation so the first question
was is the metric different or giving me
different results in terms of antibody
optimal concentration
the second question is if the settings
used for acquisition play a role if the
data type Raw versus and mix for our
units it has a has a any impact the fact
that we can extract out of fluorescence
the type of sample preparation or
staining protocol that you're using and
finally if it matters that you use an
aurora versus a conventional instrument
so let's start with the metrics and just
to summarize these are the metrics that
we compare signal to noise ratio stain
index operation index and always
together with the percentage of positive
cells so let's go back to that well CD4
but this time I've conjugate uh APC
we're seeing
some difference from what we I was
showing you before with the byg die in
this case APC is the immersed signal so
the positives are a lower intensity all
of the concentrations can separate the
positives but we know we can see where
like around 16 that Plateau it's uh we
are in that saturation phase in the
negatives we don't see that much spread
it's given by the the instrument per se
the detectors and and the wavelengths
for these viewers anyway the point is to
compare metrics so what you're seeing in
this plot is all the uh curves for the
different Matrix the dotted line on top
is the percentage of positive why
secondary y-axis will uh guide in terms
of the numbers for all the color ones is
the stain index separation index and
signal to noise ratio and again what we
for positivity expected it's not
changing even if you use 0.5 you can
still find the CD for positives we will
see with other uh specificities how that
looks especially for low Express
antigens
but the point for all the metrics is
that when we Define optimal title all of
them gave me the same result in that
linear regression um evaluation it was
32 nanograms per test so similar
performance for all the metrics if I now
show you for example same specificity
CD4 using clone sk3 in human samples and
now across floors a b c d e PSI 7 PE
fluors that have different brightness
um like ABC dimmer PSI 7 uh brighter and
definitely peel or brighter floor what
we are seeing here in every single plot
it's a titration multiple concentrations
and once again the progression of that
titration curve very similar it's the
same antigen this depends on antigens
and antibodies but the flu or it's
changing is how intense we are getting
the positive the intensity of
fluorescence for the positives and also
the background also related to the
instrument but in general for all of
them since it's the same antibody we are
getting similar Titans similar needs of
in terms of antibody concentration to
label at saturation a certain market
like CD4 important here now that we see
how fluorochromes are going to be useful
depending on Market expression to be
able to resolve better populations so
definitely something dimly expressed PE
would be the first solution but a good
option for for APC or even something
dimmer but important that all that is
taken into consideration even though the
same antibody concentration was selected
optimal concentration for this
now showing you the the plotting of that
all the metrics so you see same marker
the trend it's very similar in where
you're getting to that Plateau which is
the uh optimal concentration as well and
how for CD4 percentage of positives it's
not that informative uh because you can
still uh gay because of separating
concentrations
so what if I have a marker that is not
that highly expressed not a lot of cells
are expressing it like cd123 so what we
are seeing is a titration from 16 to a
thousand nanograms per test and now
showing you the the metrics
percentage of positivities you see on
the secondary y-axis is less than one so
it's a different situation than CD4 but
still 16 nanograms can still give you a
good estimation of that percentage so
not that helpful there but if we look at
the metrics the trends the shape of
those titration curves for is very
similar for all of them what we got is
that's 250 for this particular conjugate
is the optimal and concentration in
terms of nanograms per test
let's now see a marker that is low
Express like TCR Gamma Delta so you
won't be able to define the positivity
that easily if you go on the lower end
and we see it right 16 nanograms you
don't clearly see the positives uh you
start getting better separation 500 is
the best because a thousand nanograms
you're getting an amplification of the
background as if I show you the metrics
uh we're seeing the same very similar
all of them are giving me 500 as the
highest and we see a drop on that metric
ball for stain index operation and even
for the ratio and that happens because
of the background right we see it on the
concatenated plot that's why it's so so
critical to have everything a metric the
concatenated plot to look at the actual
data and this case the percentage we see
how at 16 nanograms in that dotted line
on the on the graph
it's almost half of your ability to
detect the positives it's reduced by
half at low concentrations and the
highest is going to be around 500 000.
so putting those two together when it's
a dimly expressed antigenous it's our
suggestion
part of what we did was to uh understand
the correlation between metrics we were
seeing that visually but we wanted to
get numbers there was high correlation
this is for four different specificities
but once again we tested a lot of titers
and titration sets uh there was good
correlation So based on that based on
the previous conclusions and also based
on the fact that stain index is easy to
calculate this widely used we decided to
move with only that one we did the
calculation for everything but for the
the presentation purposes I'm going to
show you mainly stain index for the
other comparisons
so metrics don't seem to play a big role
even though we were expecting because
the spread for in some of them or the
negative is taken into account uh now
let's move to acquisition settings what
if I use optimal settings so if I
decrease the gains or increase them
what's the impact on the optimal title
so here showing you CD4 data three data
sets the one in the middle is optimal
settings acquisition settings which are
our scitecase settings on the left plus
50 when we increase the gains by 50 on
underride decreasing the gains by 50.
anything that goes be out of that range
it's gonna the conclusions might not
apply so just just uh warning what we
are seeing visually is that yeah if I
increase the gains the positives are
higher if I decrease the positives are
dimmer compared to the one in the center
gold standard or optimal settings but
also in the poll in the when we increase
the gains the negatives are also
increasing and mfi and spread let's see
now the The Matrix so if I show you
stain index first on the right and I'm
going to show in parallel stain index
and positives and you will see why we
part of Soviet uh but I'll explain why
more let's look at the same index stain
index tells me resolution so the higher
the value the better resolution what we
are seeing on the green line is that if
I decrease the gains resolution is
impacted expected uh but if I increase
the gains by 50 that doesn't change much
the calculation because I'm also
amplifying the background
point is that if you look at the shape
of those curves for uh optimal plus 50
minus 50 it's the same so if I want to
define the optimal titer if we did it
through those automated calculations the
title was the same around 125 nanograms
in this case percentage didn't change
expected for CD4 but important to point
it out it's a highly expressed Market
percentage it's not going to be that
informative but useful still to have the
information
so if I look at molecules that are not
that high Express like cd314 uh I
mentioned this before that cold staining
is going to be useful to know where the
positives are if they are not that
um highly expressed so we did
co-staining with cd8 and then these are
the the concatenated images once again
we see an increase in the positives
decrease if I lower the gains and the
optimal titers right in the middle let's
see the impact of that what we are
seeing again lowering the gains will
reduce your resolution we see that green
uh line for the stain index the optimal
tighter was the same
independently of the settings and
finally the uh positivity percentage of
positivity it's now playing around
because if I go down to 250 500 you see
how your ability to capture all the
positives is decreased so for this one
uh we would go with the highest uh and
an observation from this is that this
titration curve is never rich in a
saturation and that's that's something
common that we saw uh not as common but
a
very uh reflected based on the marker so
my observation for the dimly expressed
markers uh
the if it's a deeply expressed marker
and you don't reach saturation then once
again there's gonna be a lot of factors
that if you are not at saturation will
impact the quality of your staining
especially if you want to do
quantification so you might want to have
consistency in the protocol very strict
sustaining protocol in terms of all the
variables that I mentioned one more
example of a dimly Express Market that
if you reduce the gains then you might
not be able to see the population this
is for TCR Gamma Delta we call stain
with CD3 in order to find better the
positives and here the concatenated
images for changes in the gains if we
look at the plots same antibody
concentration very similar observations
that for nkg 2D and is the fact that if
I lower the gains my resolution is
degrees that based on the value for
stain index but the shape is similar so
the optimal tire would be the same and
once again how positive plotting the
positivity will definitely give you a
better idea of where your concentration
needs to be to capture all the positives
to another non-saturating
um antibody and how careful you need to
be with your staining protocol and in
that particular case
so we have an answer settings for
optimal cider don't play much of a role
but definitely they do for your
resolution
now the data type so if you have a
spectral unit or an aurora or northern
light system you're gonna have raw files
and then once you calculate and mix into
understanding a multi-color sample but
fluors are present and in What
proportion you're gonna have now a mixed
data so does it matter if I do the
titration calculation in row or in a
mixed data let's look at the data
short answer is no doesn't matter
showing ucd14 we look at the
concatenated plots it looks similar Pro
versus a mix and if I plot stain index
is exactly the same not showing
percentage of positivity because of time
this is cd57 so again if we look at this
two look the same if we look at the
titration curve looks very similar and
once we Define optimal concentration was
exactly the same value
to show you other examples see the eight
hladr uh the same doesn't really matter
if we use uh and Raw versus unmix for
hladr one thing that I wanted to point
out is that this one is also not
reaching saturation and we have seen
that the problem with this one is that
if you for the for the low Express anti
and something I forgot to mention you
can increase the concentration for this
one if you increase the concentration
your signal might be out of scale plus
the fact that each LED Arts secondary
marker and it's going to add spread into
your tertiary once also important for
each ladr that is going to be expressing
multiple populations where do you need
it if you need it for B cells probably
lower going lower it's not it's going to
be not that critical but if you care
about hladr in the T Cell active
activated T cells then you want to
capture that shoulder of positivity so
all of that will also depend on what
your cells are cells of Interest are and
the levels of expression of a particular
molecule in those cells
no effect if you use rubber to sand mix
for the optimal title what if you
extract out of fluorescence does it
matter in terms of the optimal
concentration of antibody so first here
this part will depend more on the
fluorochromes how much light a detector
that it's giving you the signal for a
fluorochrome is getting just from
unstained cells or from the outer
fluorescence and here I'm showing you
cd27 if I show you without extraction
and extraction and for the concatenated
images they look very similar where the
positives are and where the negatives
are and the background for the negatives
so expected when I calculate stain index
the curves are very similar the optimal
tighter in that orange dotted line is
the same
let me also show you another example
cd19 we get very similar visuals and you
will see how different things can be if
we go to floors that are not that are
now impacted but out of fluorescence
main message is the fluid is not
impacted
the um extraction of AF is not going to
change resolution but and the other
question the optimal Target not affected
by it
so if I now show you
um
the two more specificities 50 pe5 A10
floors that are far from where out of
fluorescence is going to give you the
highest signal no differences those
stain index curves are looking exactly
the same out of fluorescence is not
giving any extra uh added information or
benefits once again hladr how you're
getting you're not getting saturation
but increasing the concentration is
going to be detrimental so making sure
that you're selling protocol is at um
very strict it's it's critical there
what we are now going to be seeing it's
fluorochromes are impacted by
autofluorescence where we are getting a
lot of background just from out of from
and in and stained cells uh this is cd16
It's a good example but to see steenex
expressing multiple subsets right
monocytes lymphocytes so we'll see the
differences there as well
this time if I show you no extraction
versus extraction and we are seeing uh
we can tell how in no extraction the
negatives are really high in intensity
so that makes my ability to separate
from the positives a little bit more
difficult less resolution versus the AF
extraction where the negatives are down
down to zero because the AF was was
um mathematically extracted that's
reflected in the stain index curves we
are seeing green light green on top is
when we extract it out of fluorescence
higher stain index values higher
resolution expected clearly seen on the
plots but when we Define optimal title
based on the curve based on the
saturation Point that's exactly the same
so AF is not important for the optimal
title but it is for resolution now if we
look at lymphocytes lymphocytes let's
Auto fluorescence but still high levels
on buv 496 so we see those negatives on
the lower
um left plot we see those negatives a
little bit higher not right around zero
once that's extracted we see on the on
the right the negatives low over that
translate in the plot into higher stain
index better resolution but once again
the title was the same
and important for this particular one is
the fact that now by Optimal title for
monocytes is different from what I need
in lymphocyte because they had different
levels of expression of that molecule
and it's going to be the same if you had
for example whole blood with now the
granulocytes being there expressing c16
in higher amounts and maybe taking most
of the antibody so important to take
that into account what populations are
expressing and how that's changing
orders
uh other examples in buv uh dies because
that's where most of the AF it's coming
into those detectors for those eyes
primarily detectors or those eyes uh we
go from no extraction to AF extraction
if we look at the uh concatenated images
we see the difference visually and that
goes into the calculation same
conclusion extracting out of
fluorescence improves your resolution
but when you are defining the optimal
title it's not really praying at all
because the titration curves depends on
the molecule on the antigen that you are
capturing with those antibodies
um so it's going to be the same
another example again tends to be for
slow uh for molecules that are low
Express ccr7 so an option there would be
to go higher two micrograms per uh test
and to get better that saturation point
another question we get is does it
matter if I'm using whole blood or pbmcs
does it matter if I use intracellular
stain you know surface staining so let's
take a look at that the first comparison
we did was hold lot versus pvmcs to
evaluate markers expressed in the
lymphocyte population
here is gonna like out of fluorescence
effect will depend on the mark on the
fluorochrome here the differences will
depend on the marker and how any of the
steps in the sample preparation could
affect the antigen expression the
Integrity of those antigens and finally
the signal for example for cd45 uh
conjugated to Alexa fuel for Ada if I
show you the same cells titrating with
the same antibody but the different
concentrations but uh obtain uh just
through pvmcs or whole blood there's no
big differences that c45 array looks
very similar and that goes into the the
curve on the right the stain index is
very similar same thing with the optimal
title another example could be CD3
labeled with a dim dye sparklu 550 what
we are seeing is that clearly in pvmcs
the separation is lower just in the
concatenated image if you go to the
whole block now the separation is better
so there is an impact fact on how the
cells are prepped before you stain and
we see that on the stain index now two
observations the whole blood for CD3 the
stain index was definitely higher
than pvmcs and the other observation is
because of the shape of those titration
curves is different than the optimal
title will be different so important to
consider or just the observation that
for your markers for the titration
evaluation you want to follow the same
protocol use the same cells same way
they are stain or stimulated or prep and
finally the same staining protocol to
have a match on whatever could affect
the binding in this case uh related to
the antigen
to show you CD 127 ccr7 once again just
if we look at the stain index curves we
see how different they are versus the
pattern we have seen before where things
match perfectly this is not the case so
they are not the same
and then the optimal title it's
calculated differently so important to
consider once again that anything you do
to the cells before titration could
affect your patterns and finally your
optimal uh tighter
another thing that we evaluated is let's
say you stain for CD4 and after that you
will go on one hand to surface surface
stainly only and the other one CD4 is
sustained but then you will go through
fixation permeabilization to get uh
access to some intracellular targets of
other specificities let's see the the
results just from the scatter plot we
can tell that there are differences uh
so that also it's going to be impacting
other things like markers
showing you CD4 conjugated to Alexa
Fluor 647 once again here marker is
what's what's clinical and this is CD4
stain on both for surface just following
different steps after that surface
staining what we are seeing is with
surface CD4 as we were seeing before
separating well for intracellular is not
the positives are spread dimmer
intensities less separation and if we
look at the stained
graph same index graph we are seeing the
dimmer intensities are translated into a
lower stain index much much better in
surface and different titles which then
answers that question that stain
protocol is going to play a critical
role
in that case it's how whatever it's done
during the uh staining protocol fixation
of perm it's affecting your molecules of
interest and finally the quality of the
staining another example hladr
conjugated to PE fire A10 we're seeing
concatenated image on the left beautiful
staining good separation for your
positives on the right for the
intracellular no staining of each LED
artwork the intracellular protocol
that's heavily impact and the impact on
both examples it's mainly on the
positives if we look at stain index it's
much much better clearly we see that on
Surface and again this in this case
optimal title was the same it's a
non-saturated antibody but how I'm being
able to see the dimly expressors for
hladr in the surface but not really
clearly on the intracellular so things
to consider and that's why use a metric
that allows you to assess resolution
um Define percentage of positive it's a
low expressor and for hladr and in
general for any marketer make sure you
have the concatenated image to guide
your decisions
um
now uh showing you the same marker cd8
how different it could be
using the same clone just across
conjugates
surface on so on top byg by UB 805
surface basis intracellular they look
pretty similar when we compare those
concatenated plots in terms of stain
index also similar same optimal
concentration a little bit better or
better for the surface staining since
the positives are tighter or the mf5 is
going to be uh higher the the CDA what
we are seeing is when I go from surface
for intercellular in the Solar color
plots uh what you're seeing is that the
background it's increasing so the
opposite to where we were seeing in
those previous specificities now it's
the negatives that are increasing so
another potential impact of changes in
your staining protocol that it's
important to control for uh changes in
the optimal title for CDA 395 but across
a similar uh in general for all of them
being the same
um molecule around 250. what we are
getting now it's to the uh la as
comparison
frequent question
I was using a conventional do I need to
retit if I'm using now an aurora so
let's see the answers
um
this is an example this is CD4 PE you
see multiple concentrations tested the
concatenated image for the Aurora system
versus a four laser conventional
spectrometer they look similar in the
shape right the positives are a little
bit dimer on the Aurora system brighter
on the other one the negatives are
tighter on the Aurora and more spread in
the in the conventional just to in
something I want to point out for this
we use cytic acid settings in the Aurora
system and optimize settings for the
conventional making sure that the the
negative population was away from the
electronic noise in the system the point
is that since there are difference in
the intensity of the positive and in the
spread of the negative that compensates
and what we get at the end is that stain
index looks very similar for this
particular conjugate we see the curve
similar curve similar values so in this
case for both instruments the
concentration similar to the
observations we've had before for this
specificity is that we are getting
Optima concentration at 32 nanograms per
test uh independently of the instrument
so if I now go to a low express marker
because yeah if uh an optical
configuration or an optical layout it's
uh has better efficiency or better
sensitivity then I will be able to see
better team Express markers so if I look
at if you look at on the left the Aurora
system titration for TCR Gamma Delta
what we are seeing once again is that 60
nanograms that's difficult to tell still
doable still separating and then we go
and increase the concentration and see
that increase in mfi reaching a point
where you get the highest but not not
clearly seeing the saturation and lower
um in the negatives not highly impacted
it's it's far from from the issues in
terms of PE fire 700. on the other uh
plot we are seeing a four laser
conventional in terms of intensity very
similar a little bit more spread and
because of that when we calculate stain
index what we are seeing is the dark
green it's the spectral cytometer values
for that stain index are higher uh lower
resolution for the conventional but at
the end if the question was is the
optimal tighter changing across
instrument it's not the case and it
would make sense that the optimal tire
depends on the binding between an
antique and an antibody and how much
antibody you need to capture
um the expression of that marker so
supporting that there's no changes
important again also when you have a low
express marker or a low frequency
population that you monitor percentage
of positives in this case again if you
go lower you will not be seeing all the
positivity in your sample which is
something critical for every panel
now showing you nkg 2D our system versus
a four laser conventional no big changes
uh slightly uh lower on the spectral in
terms of same index but the percentage
of positive once again what's going to
guide with an antibody that is not
reaching saturation because if you go
way too lower you're losing a lot of
those gated cells and this is gating out
of the cd8 positive population as a
coasting
few more examples this is done in Mouse
um samples and now comparing a narola
system and two conventional ones
different
configurations and this is for CD4 APC
fire 750 so what we are seeing is as the
full picture of those titrations done on
different instruments we see changes in
intensity changes in in separation
changes in the background for the
negatives but let's look at the data and
the the stain index for this particular
one expected because of the detectors
that we use and the low
um gains and also uh loan noise what we
are observing is that the Aurora system
gives you higher resolution in terms of
the number for that stain index value
but the concentration that is needed to
separate better that positive population
with low background high mfi is the same
acros instrument was the same across
instrument and this is a constant
observation that we saw in other data
sets here just showing you some
representative data
and one more this time for APC comparing
multiple instruments spectral versus
conventional again the curves look very
similar slightly a better resolution for
the spectral system with this particular
conjugate but once again similar
definition of what's your optimal amount
of antibody added to your samples
so that's at the end of this
presentation so take home messages uh
starting with the fact I hope this
proves you uh this point well that
titration is so fundamental for
successful experiments in flow cytometry
and that you need to plan carefully
every step of the titration process to
have good results at the end in terms of
the conclusions from the testing is that
optimal antibody title selection will
not be impacted was not impacted by the
metric that we use to calculate
resolution by the instruments that are
up going higher or lower that by the
data uh file type robust and mix by
extracting autofluorescence or by what
instrument you're using which technology
important to emphasize something that we
already knew but part of the conclusions
that the use of full spectrum profiling
or the Aurora northern light systems uh
cytic assay settings the auto presence
extraction has a definitely an impact on
having better resolution of your data
easier separation and finally that the
optimal antibody concentration depends
highly on your cells so anything that
goes in your cells in terms of cell
preparation staining protocol you want
to assess for every marker separately
and find what the better conditions are
to get a good resolution as well thank
you so much for your attention I'll be
happy to take any questions also thank
you so much for an amazing internal team
in the applications group that help
generate this um files and all these
data sets and also thank you to FCS
Express because they they save us a lot
of time and simplify and make our
workflow more efficient by using that
titration template well thank you again
and happy to answer any questions
thank you Deanna for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you would like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have the time for so
let's get started our first question is
what do we do if the titration never
shows saturation
yeah so the few of the examples uh that
we had showed that right and it's it's
it can be the fact that the
manufacturers not really give you giving
you a concentration that it's at a
saturation Point uh so you could go
higher so if the recommended cons or
volume it's let's say five micro liters
you could test 10 microliters or check
on the concentration and go higher uh
five
um micrograms usually around two and and
one and two nanograms micrograms per
test it should be enough for most of the
antibodies but yeah if you don't get to
that point uh options that you
manufacture gives you a more
concentrated antibody uh something we
are working on and number two
understanding that if it's not a
saturation at saturation the
contribution of other variables it's
going to be higher so having a very
strict protocol in terms of your
staining controlling all the variables
that could play a role once again
temperature tighter the number of cells
that you're using uh sorry more than
Tyler the incubation times
um all of those things that could add to
the variation and the data and and as
well as technical errors right pipetting
so making sure your pipettes are are
calibrated things like that could help
with
um the other thing that that could if
it's a if it's a highly expressed market
like hledr you don't reach saturation if
you go higher as I was recommended you
will not you will things will get worse
you will get more spread and your signal
will be off scale so in that case having
a competitive assay where you add
unconjugated uh antibody in order to
reach that saturation in a different way
adding more antibody that is not having
the fluorocrine in there uh to get to
that um Plateau that would be another
option
wonderful and our next question is do
you have any recommendations on how to
titrate viability dyes
that that's a point that we didn't talk
about here and part of what I was saying
for
um titration of antibodies is that you
want your positives really high
saturation point but your negative slow
how low ideally at the same level that
when you run and stain cells so that
would apply for viability dies as well
uh the optimal title in in my hands
would be where your negatives are not
giving you that High background really
close to and staying but definitely
something that you need to test in in my
experience most of the viability dies
the op the suggested concentration is
way too high it's also depending on the
sensitivity of your instrument you might
need to go lower but I would do it
making sure you have enough dead cells
and and that you have a good um negative
control for that positives and negatives
it's gonna be critical and also
um yeah the fact that you want your
negatives really low it's it's gonna be
important especially for amine reacted
by ability dies
number one it looks like we have time
for one more question what would you
suggest if I would like to titrate a
marker that is homogeneously expressed
on all my cells so I'm missing a
negative population
yeah that's a good point it can be the
problem with a cd45 so you want your
negatives to be in contact with the
antibodies so you can assess part of
what the negative population will be
about so I was saying the negatives
the signal you get from the negatives
will depend on your instrument the noise
or the instrument settings how high your
gains are how optimized they are will
depend on your cells the outer
fluorescence and it's gonna also depend
on your floor from the non-specific
binding so uh making sure you control uh
for those uh gosh I got lost can you
repeat the question it was saying too
many things
um the question was what would you
suggest if I would like to titrate a
marker that is homogeneous
thank you the uh so in that case
if we one suggestion would be use and
stain cells Spike some and stain cells
uh issue with that is that you will
still have out of fluorescence idea the
uh uh instrument background idea but you
will not be able to assess for uh the
non-specific binding of that antibody to
anything that is present in yourself
that is not the uh specific Target of
Interest so that would be the caveat
with using uh spiking and stain cells uh
but I guess that would be the only
solution or finite tissue or a sample
that will allow you to test that better
once again ideally you want to do the
titration in the same cells that you are
planning to use in a multi-color
experiment
thank you thank you Deanna do you have
any final comments for our audience
know that if you we can provide all this
information we are going to be providing
a white paper with all this uh to our
customers soon so stay tuned thank you
so much for for staying and and your
participation
and thank you to the organizers as well
thank you again Deanna for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor scitec biosciences for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of the registration this webcast
can also be viewed on demand libraries
will alert you via email when it is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who have missed today's event until next
time bye-bye